on ne couche pas pendant le single on ne
couche pas pendant le single
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien vous êtes prêts toujours moins bien
alors quel est pour vous le comble
drenthe bien fait quel est pour vous le
comble de la misère le compte de la
misère oui alors c'est les fautes et les
faux je je je je crois aussi bien ouais
je peux aussi bien voulait souffler si
vous voulez aider moi mais je suis sûr
vous parlez très très bien alors le
compte de la misère traité que alesi
traité que et puis là il va vous aider
je vois bien qu'il fait un effort
considérable alors le compte de la
misère le compte de la misère c'est de
sasp été que bg sa mère vous a traité
que baiser sa merde oui jean d'ormesson
votre idéal de bonheur terrestre mais
reprendre ça serait démarrer un roman
démarré un peu bon la faute pour
laquelle vous avez le plus d'indulgence
les gens qui causent pas bien votre
qualité préféré chez l'homme
deux pas ces camps et sont et je serai
là lucas l'académie qui devront frères
grimm ce sera un exemple bien sûr alors
il faut pas ça lui en rouge
non voilà votre qualité préféré chez la
femme le niveau 6 ni misogynie l'opal je
vous ai mises par exemple avec eux
préfèrent la femme c'est camus c'est
qu'elles plaisent bien
c'est dieu pour vous de faire des fautes
oui si dur principal défaut facile ça
cette cause est tellement bien ce que
vous détestez par dessus tout la musique
qu'il faudra la rue le don de la nature
que vous aimeriez avoir
la rapidité par exemple
[Applaudissements]
excusez moi c'est tellement j'ai très
bien c'est très bien j'aimerais
j'aimerais j'aimerais être comme moi mon
âge et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
nos latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux